I remember saying to them I was okay
listen let's make a deal like when I'm
when I'm of age and if a year from now I
think this idea is still great and and
and I really want to get it can I get in
there like sure you've got ahold of me
Shawn's all grown up and inking himself
if you look closely at his guitar tattoo
you can see it also pays tribute to his
hometown Toronto roots I would hate to
get a tattoo that my parents hate and
then have it on me and every time I see
them just like you know covering it up
Shawn's not covering anything up these
days especially in his artistry I never
want to hide from actually what is going
on in my life with my music so what I'm
writing about you know in the luminate
is truthfully what's happening in my
life
since they won you know like my fans and
I have been very close in age so you
know as as I'm getting you know 218 and
growing up they are also and so it's
nothing is becoming less relatable
aluminate gives us a relatable and more
intimate look at the stars love life
it's like an actor having to do a scene
with another actor in a movie even
though you're married it's just a part
of the and he's no dead wise beyond his
years
Sean recently handled online speculation
around his sexuality in the most mature
way possible and conquered the rumors
head-on first of all I'm not gay second
of all it shouldn't make a difference if
it was or if I wasn't the focus should
be on the music not my sexuality I just
think like in this day and age like just
like immaturity and ignorance is just so
high it was less about my feelings via
her being hurt and more about me just
being frustrated with the immaturity of
my generation and that's kind of just
what I wanted to get across